[Music]
what are you gonna do you're gonna walk
me to death shut up
that's what's up without your friend
mama not love you
I guess it pays to be a specialist huh
no it doesn't matter if you kill me
anyway because there's something way
bigger a foot in this world than you and
me much bigger than me
and it's much
much bigger than you
call us a [__]
I don't believe in God
hi Eddie whoa
[Music]
oh yeah wow
oh no
I just put that guy's head off
I know I know it's uh I've been there
too it's not fun the one with Drake is
riot who's right is what you would call
a team leader he has an article of
weapons Jake's got his own symbiote he's
Unstoppable oh great we have got to go
we gotta go where where are we going
well I'm coming with you no it's going
to get ugly she can fight ugly trust me
yeah I can fight ugly
not today
flying team aren't prepped yet I'll be
piloting the spacecraft you yes me how
long we're loading the probe and running
Diagnostics but even fully automated you
can't pilot that craft all alone
not alone
God damn what the hell happened there we
just left Danny it is not safe for her
I'm not stuck by it you went back here
with
you with Millions
you were gonna you're gonna take the
rocket and you were gonna come back here
with an invasion Force then what were
you gonna do you're gonna go feed on the
whole planet yes but in this difference
now Eddie I have decided to stay wow on
my planet I am kind of a loser like you
but here we could be more excuse me and
I'm getting to like it here oh you like
is now do you hunt however there will be
nothing left to like if we do not stop
that rocket oh I see right when it comes
to being completely annihilated then
it's back to we it is we like it or not
it is going to take both of us cut the
[__] what really made you change
your mind
[Music]